il est avec nous en direct seven
guilbaud bonsoir bonsoir patrice jouve
une petite parenthèse sur le déroulement
du vote c'est une des circonscriptions
apparemment le récit de marie où les
gens ont eu le plus de difficultés à les
voter on est allé très tard en direct
avec notre journaliste puis les gens
attendaient des heures et des heures
avez vous une explication à ce que c'est
une préoccupation que vous avez mais
préoccupé certainement
l'explication et lens
ce qui est curieux c'est que ça très
très bien fonctionné dans la très grande
majorité des bureaux de vote mais il ya
effectivement trois bureaux de vote où
ça a été très très très problématique
alors je ne comprends pas pourquoi parce
que si le problème était systémique à
laurier sainte marie on avait vu des
problèmes partout alors ça n'a pas été
le cas il ya des bureaux il y avait
aucune attente et moi je suis passé à
côté plusieurs bureaux hier il n'y avait
que peu ou pas d'attentes alors que dans
trois bureaux en particulier ça a été
très difficile
les électeurs qui ont pu voter donc on
envoyait un message assez clair au
canada c'est comme s'il disait la classe
politique et à votre premier ministre
vous vous souvenez pas ce qu'on vous a
demandé à deux amants vous demande
exactement la même chose voici ce qu'on
souhaite un gouvernement minoritaire
libéral je vous pose la question très
simplement à ce que c'était un exercice
utile steven guilbeault
pour avoir été ministre je pense que
pendant la pandémie ça fonctionnait très
bien il y avait effectivement beaucoup
de collaborations entre les parties mais
dès qu'on a commencé à essayer de
travailler sur d'autres questions je
pense à saisissant culture et donc payer
faire payer les géants du web therapy de
conversion déclaration universelle des
droits des peuples autochtones là les
choses se sont vraiment corsé et ça
devenait très difficile j'ai entendu
beaucoup d'experts dits dira ça allait
bien au parlement belge je suis désolé
mais moi j'étais au parlement et ça
n'allait pas bien du tout oui on a
réussi à passer le budget mais de peine
et de misère est là et tous les projets
de loi qu'on réussisse à faire part à
six autres que ceux sur la pandémie
c'est excessivement difficile un des
sujets de préoccupation des électeurs on
l'a vu on l'a vu qu'on a demandé des
questions pour le dernier débat en
français c'est la question du
réchauffement climatique que vous
connaissez mieux que tout le monde à peu
près qui nous écoutent et qui nous
écoutent guilbeault dans un an et demi à
deux ans est ce qu'on sera encore en
train de dire ben là on a un bon plan
mais fois être patient avant de voir une
baise des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre à quel moment on va commencer à
voir les fruits de ce que vous dites
être un bon plat des libéraux mais lors
des prochains inventaires d'émissions de
gaz à effet de serre suite 2020 mon
collègue le ministre hawkins on le dit
déjà gelé je lis répéter 2019 et la
dernière année où on va avoir une
augmentation d'émission de gaz à effet
de serre au canada évidemment si les
gouvernements continuent de mettre en
oeuvre des mesures mais en ce qui nous
concerne vous allez voir les émissions
vont diminuer en 2020 et 2021 et par la
suite tant que non nous aurons à ottawa
un gouvernement qui est sérieux en
matière de lutte aux changements
climatiques
les émissions vont continuer de diminuer
parce que beaucoup de canadiens ont
encore la difficulté à résoudre
l'équation entre deux nouveaux projets
gaziers ou pétroliers entre le pipeline
d'un côté et de l'autre côté ce discours
là en disant on va s'attaquer très
sérieusement problème
sursaut sur le pipeline je comprends
très bien j'ai d'ailleurs fait campagne
en 2009 en disant que j'étais contre ce
projet là mais je vous ferai remarquer
par contre at risk il n'y a eu aucune
approbation par le cabinet de nouveaux
projets de production d'hydrocarbures
que ce soit pétrole gaz ou charbon
depuis 2019 aucun nouveau projet qui
était approuvé par par le cabinet 7 ces
transitions lot dont nous discutons
depuis
il n'y en a pas dans
les pas de loi qui était adoptée qui dit
qu'il n'y en aura pas d'autres
certainement dans le code charbon
effectivement n'aura pas donc nous
l'avons déjà annoncé et dans le cas du
pétrole et du gaz l'un des engagements
importants de notre de notre plateforme
c'est de dire aux mains plafond sur la
pollution du secteur du pétrole et du
gaz pourquoi parce que c'est 25% la
pollution climatiques au canada alors si
des nouveaux projets mais ils vont
devoir
ils vont devoir être sous ce plafond le
donc ça va devenir très très difficile
mais vous pourriez dire aussi c'est vrai
mais bon y'en aura pas d'autres nouveaux
projets mais non parce que comme vous le
savez très bien la production des
ressources naturelles c'est de
juridiction provinciale
là où le fédéral peut intervenir comme
on le fait avec le prix sur la pollution
par exemple c'est au niveau de la
pollution alors la cour suprême nous a
dit clairement sur les questions de
pollution le gouvernement fédéral peut
intervenir mais si on essayait si on
essaie de dire aux promesses de plus
vous pouvez plus développées telles
ressources et là ce serait excellent
excessivement problématique alors on
doit y aller du côté de la pollution
s'est laissé les leviers que nous avons
au niveau du gouvernement fédéral exact
est-ce que vous souhaitez être le
prochain mines et de l'environnement la
prônent la première fois qu'on prenait
bien tour ne voulaient pas a été
prudemment mines et du patrimoine c'est
très bien est-ce que vous souhaitez
aller travailler dans le domaine qui
vous passionnait une partie votre vie
je dirais que c'est c'est la question
qui qui m'a passionné toute ma vie
adulte le jure je n'ai fait presque ça
y est je continue d'être très passionné
j'ai continué de travailler au cours des
dernières années j'étais sur le comité
du cabinet sur l'environnement et
l'économie c'est sur le comité de la
relance verte j'ai amené au g20 de la
ministre des ministres la culture le
proposer à la présidence italien qu'on
inscrive le rôle des arts et de la
culture dans la lutte aux changements
climatiques dans la déclaration du g20
dont large et continue de m'intéresser à
ça moi je pense que ça nous prend 338
personnes au parlement qui se
préoccupent de changements climatiques
au premier ministre de décider patrice
comme vous le savez très bien mais vous
seriez pas fâché évidemment bien sûr que
non seven guilbaud députés réélus
libéral dans l'eure et sainte-marie
merci nous n'avons pas merci beaucoup